okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is a hmm slightly
different thing that I've been doing the
last few weeks this is beginning to
return to my day job of designing
Wolfram language and but still thinking
about beginning to think about what we
can learn from what we have figured out
about physics to inform um the what
we're doing in both language design and
so the thing we're going to look at
today is kind of a particular case of
essentially what amounts to distributed
computing that I have been thinking
about one way or another for 40 years
and I'm so frustrated I haven't been
able to figure it out so let's see
whether in the next hour or so we can
make progress all right what we are
looking at is Combinator's and the idea
here is let's see where's our best
implementation of combinators that we
can um um we can play with the I think
we had looked at okay that the big issue
is so combinators like where do we have
a good version of combinators here ah ba
ba ba ba I think we had the notion of a
Combinator simplify right so let's write
down what it is we're trying to do here
so first thing we have is um okay we're
thinking about thinking about standard
combinators you know standard
Combinator's IEG SK but in general we
could have we could have any lambda
basically to represent to correspond to
a well well what is the general case of
what we might consider to be
accommodator did I lose everybody here
I'm not sure everybody here knows
exactly what a Combinator is I mean I'm
aware they exist but if you ask me to
define them I would be totally lost well
okay so look the special case of
combinators that's 100 years old and due
to our friend Moses shown Frankel um oh
I gotta show you something I gotta show
you this thing maybe I already showed
you this but but Tim ah let me see if I
can pull it up hold on um gosh okay so
let's let's look at um the sort of the
that's 100 years old is this idea of
representing we looked at in for example
here where we're looking at
representation of where we have these
Combinator's s and K and we have these
Combinator expressions like this and
then we are evaluating those Combinator
expressions as a way to do computation
make sense what is a common Eider so the
generalization that I had in nks was
what I called symbolic systems um so
let's take a look at what those were
okay so those were things which were of
the form some head here ok so ok so
first question what is a Combinator ok
so one possible definition is um it's a
head with various tentacles that doesn't
sound very appetizing but but um okay so
example would be I've clicked a copy
here know something like e of X blank oh
wow that's weird
we actually quit my kernel here to make
sure I don't have anything too bizarre
to find ok um e of X blank Y blank
colony calls or arrow X of X of Y so in
other words it's something of the form
um okay so it's a head with various
curried arguments I would claim right so
can Roman can you speak up please yes I
mean yes I mean that's exactly it's a
symbol with certain with there's a
single operation binary application and
there is some simplification of
transformation who will whenever that
element appears with a minimum number of
arguments okay so so ahead with curried
arguments but now there are no literals
here right this is just
um in the the you know the only the only
literal is the head correct well in the
rule yes right um we could have rules
that involve several coordinators or
that I think this is referred to as a
primitive Combinator as something that's
defined by a single reduction law in
combinatory logic and then you can have
compound ones as opposed they said that
that are because you know there are two
fundamental there's really only one
fundamental operation combinatory logic
which is application and so then by
applying different Combinator's to each
other by applying different primitive
Combinator's to each other you can
produce composite ones that are
effectively defined by multiple
reduction rules as hosea says okay so
someone on the livestream is pointing
out that accommodation is pure function
without any free variable which is but
but here but the arguments are being
curried here so that's another another
feature right we're we're this could be
right okay this is what I'm trying to
understand okay so so it's a head
without various with various tentacles
ie it's a pure in the sense of no
external it's a pure function with a
certain number of arguments I mean what
what is the right definition here
guys let's okay I think the correct
definition that we should really be
thinking about is pure function with
certain number of arguments pure
function no external data no external
data no external dependencies with a
certain number of arguments okay now
what we what is the I mean in the case
of in in the purest case the only thing
the function does is application is
function application right it has no it
has no pluses or anything else inside it
right yes okay by the way for people who
are wondering what on earth this has to
do with physics we are going to get to
that very soon um the okay all right so
then and by convention
everything is curried um okay so then we
have the standard combinators standard
combinators eg the shown Finkel
Combinator's okay and let's just remind
ourselves what those Combinator's
actually are um and they should be these
ones here two Combinator's okay s of
explain why blank c blank goes to X of Y
Z Y wives eke a ghost is that okay so in
our design I mean people have defined
like there's the Y Combinator which is a
fixed point Combinator there's a bunch
of other Combinator's can be defined
purely in terms of function application
right yes okay all right so then we've
got combinators like these ones here
that are like these are the church
numerals where we can define 0 is this
Combinator expression in chram
is this combinator expression okay so
then when we want to get to we just say
incremental increment of zero and we get
that presumably now I don't know whether
that's and simplified for me we have to
this is this is where things start
getting interesting oops because now
we're applying these Combinator rules
and in that particular case it did
nothing but presumably if we apply the
power Combinator let's do that let's
define the power Combinator here um and
we say power of presumably let's say two
to the two to the two to the three for
example right we should be able to get
that with this here if I'm not mistaken
yes and now this thing however if we
reduce it do you need to use it in
everything I absolutely do otherwise it
doesn't have a hope okay so that should
be so we need a the Combinator decoder
here would be so this should be 2 to the
power 3 right so let's see whether that
is 2 to the power of 3 we can say nest
of increment on 0 6 2 to the power 3 at
8 times ok why isn't this not equal did
I get something wrong
um I think we have encountered that last
time I think it only collapses if you
then apply it to something all right I
mean zero by itself is represent 0 times
application of a function so to actually
do something you have to say zero of f
so you claim that we have to do what we
have to do is this applied to let's say
K for example do you believe that yeah
and one more so this is a times applying
K and now you have to apply it to
something okay okay yes so that is
correct right
hey times application of cake okay yeah
all right okay okay okay
all right so the thing that comes out
then is a power is a function then
numerals are our curried forms of nest
right yes twice curried nest of n
applied to F apply to X gives F n times
of f of X okay all right I believe you
okay now let's see where things start to
get really hairy okay because let me
look at this
let's see okay let's
let's look at
I'm trying to find a case where things
start to go really crazy so what we've
got that the big issue is is it going to
terminate upon combinator reduction
right so if I do this ah I go so goes
away for a very long time by the way the
question of whether pure s terms
terminate is decidable I just learnt
that recently because I met a former
colleague of mine who wrote his PhD
thesis about s terms about two years
before me with the same CCD advisor and
so at this 90th birthday we we all met
and I asked him and he said yes it's not
settled it's decide about whether these
s terms terminate or not okay well
that's interesting I mean so but let's
understand what's going on here okay so
the main issue is and we need a way to
represent what's happening and this is
where things are gonna get complicated
right this this thing let's say we say
nest lists of this applying C rules to
this right okay this is where things get
really hairy right because what's
happening here is this is Jack Godwin a
horrible mess look at this crazy thing
okay so let's let's look at that and
let's look at how do we figure out what
would we want to say leaf count to get
the sizes of these expressions right and
let's say 50 times men getting huge okay
so
is getting to be 24 million an
expression of size 24 million okay so
the question is does this terminate or
not but the more interesting question is
what's the correct evaluation order
because what happened here is we've got
this expression and it's essentially got
this evaluation front of where is this
substitution actually happening and
they're making sense because there are
many different ways right it could be
the case that one evaluation order does
not terminate but another one does yes I
mean this is sounds typical with
Combinator set in wall of K because K
swallows arguments so if you simplify KD
before the argument it goes away but if
you go into the argument may never
terminate okay so why is this relevant
to anything okay the issue is what's
going on here you know what we need to
think about is essentially an evaluation
front otherwise known as and this is
where I'm hoping we can make a multi-way
system out of this and try and
understand what it's doing because the
different evaluation orders the
different reductions are like you know
picking different updates in the
multi-way system let's give another I
mean the other analogy we've looked at
before is recursive evaluation so let's
just look at the cases here cases of
evaluation control okay so one case is
combinators eg Combinator's where it's a
question of basically where it's
Slashdot repeated repeated substitution
what do you substitute first right
another case is eg recursive definitions
you know f of X Planck colony calls
something involving F you know something
like this what do you have what do you
transform what do you evaluate /
transform first yes now these two cases
are clearly very similar right although
they may not be I mean in this case here
in the case of the you know the even the
factorial case right we have an issue
there because if we are just doing this
in the most default way of doing this
what we will have so let's do this with
an arrow here well that's actually not
going to work correctly because this
here if we do that with an arrow and we
say nest list hash / dot that um Amba's
and F of 10 comma 15 or something we
will get that right but in actuality if
we were to evaluate this directly with
assignment that would not do this
because it would never notice that it's
getting 0 times some number because it
would just keep drilling on the F am I
making sense yeah I mean dominatus you
don't have these extra operators that
may simplify so no I understand what I'm
saying is the issue here what I'm trying
to define is there's an evaluation front
right like imagine we're doing Fibonacci
okay there's going to be a tree that's
generated and there will be an
evaluation front that says what to do
next
am I making sense yes okay so my big
question is how do we parameterize that
evaluation front right and my claim is
that the parameterization is just like
the parameterization of reference frames
that we've had to do in physics sure I'm
saying oh let me be more specific
okay so let's say we go um I don't
whether people have I mean
ah let me see um let's say I'm trying to
find the relevant place remember whether
says I think it's I think it's um how do
I discuss this um so that's it
no come on where is it
anybody know this well enough to know
where it is um I'm trying to remember
where I had I had a nice set of pictures
of I wonder where the searching works
here and I said uh pictures of eco
that's not where it is um this is where
it is okay all right so think of this I
mean this could be a recursion yes no
maybe this is a set of evaluations that
you're doing in this particular case
it's it's gotten from the you know
success of string rewriting right did
you go what I'm saying yeah I mean could
you
for example Fibonacci where you always
have to do two and Tomita ones combined
yeah I think so I think this is like
Fibonacci except the tree doesn't happen
to have this shape because it's a
Fibonacci tree so it has slightly
different shape but it's the same idea I
think um but the issue is this is the
standard depth first way of evaluating
the recursion yes actually yes right
okay this will be some kind of breadth
first scan right so now when we think
about foliation x' right what we're
doing there how do we think about this
this is this is this is what I'm trying
to understand how do we think about this
parameterizing this you know
breadth-first this depth-first all these
other complicated things
many of them are incomprehensible
frankly
they're weird orders but then we have
this notion of a reference frame where
we are providing a foliation that is
some kind of very organized ordering of
the evaluation that's what I'm hoping we
can figure out is how to parameterize
sort of organized orderings of
evaluation anybody following I don't see
why this should be done in an ordered
way I mean cannot be just anyone and
then any other one this looks like you
need a position argument to say act on
these specific mm-hmm well okay so the
question of whether you can do it in any
order is essentially a causal and
variance question and the answer is no
in general what Commodore a Turing logic
is known to be non confident there are
boolean extensions of it that are known
to be consonant but just and the CL is
not even for the SK Combinator's well
they SK Combinator is a universal so
yeah SK and I universal well if you if
you if you take common combinatory logic
and you a pet you have a bit essentially
a join boolean constants then you could
eat then it was a fairly recent result
in logic that that system is complement
and complete or terminating incomplete I
should say okay so wilmut so first
statement is okay so the claim is that
combinators on their own okay the first
claim which i just want to remember here
is termination of s X s Combinator
combinations is decidable so is it
obvious but but by which you mean that
there exists a path by which the thing
can be made to terminate is that correct
well no I mean you can tell whether it
terminates or not and essentially no but
their commune salivation order where it
doesn't terminate even though is that
correct or does
have to terminate for all evaluation
orders I think because the dammit what I
understood I mean I haven't looked at
the results that just I mean I can find
it if if you're interested but they're
probably the intuition is here is
correct because s terms don't destroy
information so it always grows and so
you can at some point you know that it
can never stop but it will just keep
going okay well it's not comfortable we
don't actually know in the the infinite
case is probably less clearly understood
sorry yeah the SK combinators maybe
confluence in cases where you
effectively don't have conditionals that
I would have to look into I know that if
you just have SK Combinator's and a
conditional then it's definitely not I
thought that they were confluent
actually that's my recollection yeah I
mean it would make sense given that you
can translate lambda terms into
accommodators but there are certainly
case I mean there's a big paper called
Combinator reduction systems that I
looked at just before this meeting that
that has a bunch of these kind of
confluence results and there are
certainly variants of combinatory logic
that don't have confluence whether the
SK Combinator's without conditionals
have confluence or not I don't actually
know right okay there's an explicit
example here of a nought of a non
complement combinatory logic system
which they then modify it
to be confident okay so this is an
example of one where this is the SK
Combinator's so then the others and the
system shown just below the SK
Combinator's is known to be non
confluent i see so there is something to
be represented in terms of calm of
combinators and although it's not clear
what T and F are here I assume this then
Fort Ord Falls right I see so they're
fixed terms yes see that is not a type
well yeah all right so okay Roman do you
know whether the SK Combinator's a
confluent no I don't I would think they
are not because I mean in the simplest
case you can have one chain that doesn't
terminate and another chain that does
terminate so let me show you something
cannot be conflict we just recently got
this is from 1927 did I show you this
yet this is fun this is this is notes by
Haskell curry in which Haskell curry has
more or less independently discovered
combinators and then he found the paper
by Shawn Finkel and the most remarkable
thing about these notes is the use of an
@ sign for function application
don't you think that's cute and it's
this exact same thing that we're doing
but lost it at sign of it I thought it
was young which the at sign yet sir the
add sign existed in 1927 I know very I
mean the add sign did not come with
ASCII keyboards it used to be the case
when I was a kid at least that it would
be like you would see five apples at
three shillings or something um I wonder
whether his precedence works the same
way there must be from looking at this I
would say it's left associative um
father is Matthew here and as he can he
speak I'm here yeah okay so do you know
the answer this yes yes I do so so so
first of all all Combinator's are
consequent in fact that's the
church-rosser property right Matthew
speak up okay so uh no no I can't hear
you I can hear you I can hear you just
fine
I said I was meaning that in general
we've been talking about this and you
already knew the answer so okay tell us
what is actually more to say the you are
also getting termination confused with
confluence so you can have these
Combinator expressions well there
they'll terminate for some evaluation
order but they don't always terminate
for all evaluation orders that's what I
thought was the case right yeah that's
what happens if you have one that's
defined recursively you so there will be
one evaluation the order where it might
just keep going and rehearsing forever
but there'll be another way to like take
one branch out right can we have can we
get straight the first question okay is
combinatory logic does it it has the
church-rosser property yes correct under
strong reduction what does that mean as
in not under Ito reduction yeah well
we don't have to really worry about that
so okay let's let's understand this
confluence of Combinator's okay what is
Ito reduction and I remember it's it's
it's a variance of beta reduction for
combinators okay so it's we're basically
only doing beta reduction beta reduction
is when you do function application
that's really all we're basically doing
in this case okay so can you tell us the
result okay first question if I give you
a Combinator expression okay
is it the case that if it terminates
then it will always terminate at the
same thing true or not true correct that
comes from the Churchill Rosser property
okay so the claim is church-rosser
implies that if the Combinator
terminates
if the Combinator reduction terminates
it always terminates at the same result
that determination is unique there's Y
unique normal form is the terminology
that's usually used fine it always
terminates at a unique normal form okay
but there any given scheme for
evaluating the Combinator may or may not
terminate correct correct
there is one scheme that's known to
always terminate if it does terminate I
believe that leftmost outermost its
leftmost outermost yes great
or maybe no is leftmost outermost okay
okay um but that's sort of infinitely
lazy I mean yeah okay we will discuss
that in a minute leftmost outermost and
I mean that was what when I thought
about this before like four years ago
that was what I was trying to emulate
was a parameterization of leftmost
outermost to rightmost innermost and so
on um okay we have somebody on the
livestream pointing out that the outside
was first used in the 16th century
um interesting um okay so okay so first
point is if it terminates it always
terminates in a unique normal form but
different evaluation orders may or may
not lead to termination correct correct
okay if it doesn't terminate it is also
the case that there exists a way to get
you'll never get stuck true statement
that is if you look at the multi way
system it will have our causal
invariance property true or not true I
don't understand the question okay if I
were to look at if I were to compute a
multi-way graph from a common Eider is
it the case that the multi way graph
will have the caused limb variance
property my guess would be the answer is
yes that's what I think - um okay so
let's try let's try - okay so again our
objective here is to understand okay so
I think what we should do next is try to
actually make a multi-way system from
combinators okay just so we see what it
what it means to do different evaluation
orders on one of these combination
expressions because what we're seeing
here like this expression here gets very
big i thought i'm sure i'm you know i
know that in the encash book i had
worked out what the simplest Combinator
expressions that get to certain sizes
and so on is you know like this one it
says grows to a maximum size of one to
six three and then um let's try that one
okay let's say we go to a hundred steps
okay so with this evaluation order but
this evaluation on to notice this thing
so you claim that the fixed point that
this eventually ends up with right if I
just say nest here that's ending up with
a fixed point that is that right
somewhere in the middle here um you know
so I'm trying to understand if I can
think about this you know the different
reductions happening here and can I
think about this as some kind of you
know what will be the reference frames
that what is the foliation that
corresponds to a certain evaluation
order here that makes sense
Matthew do you understand what I'm
talking about here no no IIIi mean and
of course that that's what we're doing
we're trying to find the connection
between these two different ideas that
they seemed like they should be
connected but we're not sure exactly
what the connection is yes right I mean
look evaluate how would we parameterize
let's think about a pure language design
how would we parameterize this
evaluation order so here /c rules is
just going through and the first time it
can apply one of those rules well it's
trying to do as many rule applications
as possible okay so we could write this
differently if we wanted to by saying um
so that this down here so we say um you
know different orders of rule evaluation
or you know different evaluation orders
okay so this one here let's just do this
hold on let me show you something so I
reckon if I say nest this I don't know
20 times or something I'm gonna get some
big complicated combination expression
right okay so if I take that expression
let's call that e e is that I take that
combination expression and I say slash
dot C rules that's gonna do some
reduction on that thing okay but if I
were to take that and I would say and I
believe that doesn't multiple that okay
actually if I say replace list actually
this is gonna make a big mess I think if
I do this
okay replace list of that comma C rules
that why does it do that
I thought replaced list Oh Oh it's only
going at the top level people understand
the issue here so the point is that that
is applying so what we really want to do
is to same at all of replace list of
commerce' rules this isn't quite right
but did anybody see how to do this
better
oh gosh see what this is doing
um yeah good point
um did you understand what I'm trying to
deal here no so you want to look at each
node and see I want to look at all
possible replacements yes can be going
for each node there's probably only one
zero replacement fine so let's go figure
out in these nodes okay so then what we
want to do is a match queue on these
nodes right so on the node each node
will say match q2 so let's take C rules
right and let's turn that into a pattern
I'm just making that a vertical bar can
you add the option hits goes to do
double in this one here you just think
is it's it's matter of not applying two
heads
oops that's goes to true no ok so then
this is the pattern that we are trying
to figure out whether it matches okay so
that's our pattern and now what we want
to know is as we recurse through this
tree
where
um yeah I think we want to combine
position with you find all find our
positions we have this matches right
that's what we want to do so I guess
what we just say is position in let's
say EEE
or it lets us to start off with the
initial thing position in there of C
pattern okay now let's say that really
right that it only matches in one place
well let's do it on the EE thing
I bet this needs a heads well let's try
heads arrow true okay let's try the same
thing for that eee object okay
so that's showing us where this pattern
could be applied in that object right so
now the question is which of these
applications do we actually do so let's
let's take a look at this as a you know
as we go through the nest here as we go
through successive levels of nesting so
this is gonna tell us for each level of
nesting so we say nest list here and
we'll say let's say whatever it was 200
times and then for each one of those we
go through and do this this is exactly
what we designed proof object for okay
well then let's use it but hold on let's
let's first of all we get this okay so
here this so now this is telling us how
many possible um okay so that's giving
us the map of how many possible
applications there were at each a step
right okay so this is telling us the
level of ambiguity at each step
basically and in the end
it goes down to zero ambiguity but what
okay
well Jonathan so we've got a couple of
different things we can do here so what
proof tries to do is to find a path to
if we say the fixed point is blah yes
find then it should give us an optimal
path through here this is one path what
we got here by doing this nest list is a
particular path through a series of
reductions okay so so and by the way I'm
still not convinced about this whole
church-rosser thing in the sense that
Combinator's of as we have defined them
above as effectively pure function well
as pure functions with no external
variable dependencies
those can be symmetric you can have
symmetric reduction rules which means
that they're not equivalent to lambda
calculus they're equivalent a symmetric
lambda calculus which doesn't have the
church-rosser property what is symmetric
lambda calculus well let lambda calculus
where beta reduction can be symmetric
what do you mean by symmetric so you can
transform in both directions okay which
well which is something we allow with
the definition that you gave above I
think okay let's put that on side and we
need to answer that but let's let's
understand this for a second so okay I
mean yes it's symmetric once you allow
symmetric reductions it's definitely not
confluent because you can simulate
equation illogic no III would actually
disagree with you I think when you say
symmetric reductions Yoshi would mean
what's called a conversion conversion
means you don't know with the reduction
of the reverse reduction and and it
doesn't really matter it's still it's
still obeys toward Rosser mmm really
yeah okay there are a lot of incorrect
papers then I'll give it so Jonathan is
putting papers in a chat here that
claimed other things so let's take a
look at these papers than ever
well here's this is it symmetric landok
well that's the symmetric combination
case is the symmetric lambda case they
both make claims of non church-rosser
which would
cents because I think well if it were
the planets that which one is the
Combinator case the first one you
designed the project Euclid one Sonos
electric combinatory logic that contains
at least two symmetric Combinator's has
the church-rosser property which would
make sense because otherwise if it were
the case that you could construct
symmetric reductions now and still have
a compliment I'm rewriting system then
this would mean you could do equational
theorem proving without the need for
completion which would be amazing if
they're improving in what in cometary
logic yeah so you're saying that if
there is confluence then you don't need
completions then you should be able to
do just a one a one-shot version of I
don't know that's true because we're
efficient see I mean it might be the
case that you need completions to
essentially store lemmas that otherwise
you'd have to recurse back on but we
beat it you don't need to do completion
to do that you know it's a store
substitution learners you don't need to
do completion alright let's let's look
at this a little bit more experimentally
I you know that's okay so first point is
okay so pause through the network of
possible reductions okay we've got to
know in ways that we can do that right
way number one is the slash dot or slash
slash dot approach right that's one no
one way to go through that network
okay so slash slash dot is one of them
another way is essentially find find
equational proof right that will be
another way to get through the network
of possible reductions correct do we
have any other ones is there one with
with grow us less slash slash dot
actually do from the insider from the
outside
it starts from the beginning of the
expression it recursos the expression
tree and it uses I believe that I don't
know what it does in these deeply nested
red trees if it was a what it normally
does is it will go and back up the
recursion and then it will try running
each rule at each level in the recursion
did that make any sense so my claim is
that if I do this if I say F of a a B B
slash dot um you know a goes to X B goes
to Y it could be the case right it does
that okay now if I do this if I say a of
a here it I was not expecting that why
does it do that why does it do that it
tries to do the maximal reduction I know
tries to do the maximal reduction
without recursing did you get what I'm
saying oh I know what I know what
happened I know what happened here if I
were to change this end to yeah if I
were to have something less trivial here
if I would have a of X blank goes to you
know um ax of X okay then I believe it
will only do it one level here you could
also just change that B goes to a I
think that will also illustrate the
difference Oh
you're saying okay so in this case here
that didn't that didn't do the inner
recursion but it did come back out if I
were to have this as a of you here it
comes back out and does that one did you
get what I'm saying so it so is it out
the most mm-hmm no I don't well yes I
think it's outermost but I don't think
it's pure leftmost right because what
it's doing is it's doing multiple pieces
here okay Jonathan what were you saying
here you were saying though you take
your example and you change that to B
goes to a that will illustrate the
difference right because the point is
slash dot is not iterating until a fixed
point where a slash slash slash slash
dot is well I think with the this was a
different issue I mean so B goes to a
here okay if what if I were to now do
slash slash dot here this would just
request for ever no oh yeah because it's
to a fixed point right that's the point
yeah but it tries to get to a fixed
point using a certain evaluation order
and that evaluation order may or may not
so let's give an example where there is
an evaluation order where it would get
to a fixed point but slash slash dot
doesn't find it okay so i'm i'm pretty
sure a bunch of these common Eider
things have that property that that
there is a way to get to a fixed point
but slash slash dot doesn't get there
that makes sense but if it is out the
most end it would find a fixed point
that's in the theory that that's okay it
doesn't okay in practice is more
complicated for reasons that the
original definition of leftmost
outermost had to do with the evaluation
of recursive functions at least as of i
when i last looked at this which was
basically nineteen eighty you know it
had to do with a specific model of
evaluating recursive functions and by
the time you have these more structural
symbolic expressions it wasn't clear
that applied
okay um so III think it's more look can
we try to make the multi way system from
Combinator's is that um I mean there are
two things we could try to do I think
that's the most useful thing to try to
do is to make the multi way system for
Combinator's and then I mean the thing I
really want to get to is how do we
parameterize this you know is it clear
what the problem is first question is it
clear what the problem is the problem is
say it again slash slash dot has a
particular essentially recursion order
right : a calls has another recursion
order that makes sense and the question
is can we parameterize that recursion
order in some meaningful way in
particular can we use so Jonathan says
yes as in he understands the question or
he has a way to do it well that's what
proof object us as I said is what it's
parameterize as evaluation fronts how
through
operations and part specifications if
you know I mean what what it says right
let's go look at that but I mean what
it's doing is it's saying what it did
right what I'm saying is to be able to
say in advance what you want to have
happen because proof object is an
after-action report so to speak in other
words these things worked in getting the
proof object right right but you can't
you can't specify reference frames in a
causal graph for a non-causal invariant
system a priori because the different
reference frame joyce's will lead to
different outcomes so that they will
constrain what reference frames you can
take in future sure so for a non-causal
invariant system that's the best you can
do isn't after and you know and after
the fact report well not necessarily
because what you try okay
let me understand what the analogy is
between this and like grosvenor basis
orderings okay so we've got yet more
issues here okay so another one here is
governor basis orders which I've never
understood whether the same as Kenneth
Bendix orders the cliff that the
Grosvenor basis reduction order is the
same as the colonel vendek reduction
order but for a you know finitely
presented on Lloyd I don't understand
I send you a few minutes ago or notebook
with a connection of combinators on any
personal proof
so what is this this is so we had seen
this before so so we have their rules
for combinator actions at the beginning
in the language that find the co sheriff
will understand and then there are a
couple of examples of proofs of results
given image okay so let me just save
this in the right place yeah um that is
definitely not the right place um sorry
just a second
you
just go ahead and save it there um okay
okay
now what is this so this is saying this
is the axioms for Combinator's here
right so we are using left T or this
Combinator apply operator that Ramon
wants to have Europe and then just go to
Syrian one film - okay so this is saying
this is so - let me write that out in a
different form
okay so how do I translate your thing
with left t into my version with just a
function application is that okay so
you're saying this thing here and at is
the same as construct is that true oh
yes thank you
okay all right and that's just also
change s goes to lowercase s okay goes
to lowercase K okay all right so that's
that and so now we do that thing slash
dot C roll slash slash dot okay so
that's X so that's what that reduction
gives so this is now saying you can find
that reduction by an equation all proof
and here's the proof object okay so
let's let's do that them saying is that
the object will now report in which
these things were them right
so those Combinator axioms okay so now
we say in here here's our theorem
so this is now the proof object and so
now now we get out so we'd say that um
what do we once a proof data set right
right okay so now
Jonathan's statement about where it did
its thing yeah if you look at the inside
of a substitution lemma for instance
well in this particular case it applied
at position 1 which is not super
exciting ok well let's try the next case
then let's try the next case which is
more complicated um but my point is just
that the substitution lemma that the
design of the individual proof of a
substitution lemma is a parameterization
of an evaluation order yes I mean
although we've never really liked it
very much I mean this part numbers are
kind of a grotesque way to do that do
you agree on MIM ok so let's take try
taking this um ok so there I see so
those positions there are the positions
in the currently achieved state of the
universe so to speak saying where the
rule will get applied next correct sure
so this is essentially one branch of a
multi-way system that successfully gets
to the fixed point
right and your claim is that not all
branches of the multi-way system will
act similarly a Matthews claim as they
will so we're um well if you restrict
yourself to SNK combinators then yes
they will but if you allow for symmetric
combinator reduction then I'm pretty
sure they weren't oh yeah I still
haven't understood what symmetric
combination reduction is symmetric
combinate I don't think it's something
we need to consider so so uh the
definition here that I'm taking out of a
paper is that a a symmetric Combinator
x2 a symmetric lambda calculus
combinators are considered to be part of
lambda calculus symmetric lambda
calculus is lambda calculus where
expressions and continuity and
expressions and continuations are
treated in a symmetric manner so just as
a way that you might abstract over
expressions um to receive an argument of
an expression the article says we can
abstract over continuations in symmetric
lambda calculus to capture the current
continuation this is something from
theoretical computer science that I
think it is not necessarily relevant to
what we're doing I think we're just
doing classic our lambda calculus we're
not we're not doing the symmetric lambda
calculus okay so we're not we're not
sure but that's the okay let's work on
that hypothesis okay so we have one
example here of where you can see you
know eh
okay so can we try to actually get the
multi way system okay now we're we're
depending on um um okay so we need the
this is Jonathan's story because he's
the one who knows multi way system
because he wrote most of it um
pull up multi way system
okay so this is the documentation for
multi-way system okay so the challenge
here is to define using using these
things right the state of your evolution
function state equivalents function etc
to define accommodator reduction yeah
right which is fairly easy once we agree
upon a design okay so let's take as our
minimal design okay which is not gonna
be the final design right minimal design
we're just talking about you know s of K
of K about whatever okay I think we
should do that rather than should we do
that rather than left T design comments
from people I mean just just for the
sake of generating something that we can
look at let's do this instead of the s
over the left T design right so this is
the this type of thing will be the form
of a combination expression okay okay so
now the question is we need to write
down these um this thing by the way if
you were claiming right before this
meeting that Turing machine was a
supported type it's not listed here is
it in fact a supported type who is
claiming this you were what well when
you were talking about non-deterministic
Turing machines in the fact that I
messed up my understanding of them you
were saying that multi right system
supports Turing machines no no I was
saying that well any any computation
performed by multi ways system can be
viewed as a Turing machine computation
and depending on the event selection
function it changes the type okay but we
don't specifically have
non-deterministic Turing machines
supported yet no okay fine um think I
had one example of one of those okay so
oh I was okay so can we just work out
what for this representation of
combinators right probably not our final
one let's try to work out what these
things are to get a multi-way system for
combinators so the goal is to draw the
multi way system this is probably an
ambitious one to draw it for but to draw
the multi way system for one of these
combination reductions
makes sense so where do we start here we
want a state evolution function right
right which will be a replace list of
the of whatever the reduction term is is
it just a replace list because the
replace list is only going to go at the
top level so I'm saying so I mean let's
start off a state evolution function is
something which takes which has got to
take this for example and it's got to
apply C rules in all possible places
correct yes
once in all possible places so I think
what we want to do there is we want to
say um we want to do a replace if I'm
not mistaken with C rules and we want to
then map that what do we want to do we
want to we want to take all possible
positions here in this thing and we want
to do the replacements from all possible
positions is that right so we want to
say um how do we find
more positions here I mean clearly we
can just say position of what what's
wrong with using replace list here
because a replace list doesn't go
multiple levels I don't think maybe it
has an option to do that no it gives at
most n results attempts to hands form
the entire expression okay I see we mean
unless there's no level spec that's
correct
because what would it return that's the
problem replace lists normally I mean if
I say replace list of you know a of X B
of X you know well I should let me I
mean I mean in other words replace list
can only take the whole expression
because it has no way to stuff back into
a a tree wetware it replaced one part of
the tree go what I'm saying yeah I see
okay so then prevailing Network symmetry
story what
oh yes yes it's the same issue you can't
you can't plug fun back in a
substructure well yeah I mean because
the representation of the substructure
is different the representation of the
list of substructures is different from
the representation of the substructure
itself right well okay okay so what
we're trying to do here what are we
actually trying to return we're trying
to return a list of expressions where a
single replacement was done somewhere in
that expression right right so what I
mean just just to be clear on what would
happen if I say map all of F onto this
expression with heads goes to true then
I claim that will map F's in all
possible places but that's not what I
want what I want to do is I want to have
an expression where I have a list of
expressions where F has been put on all
possible parts see what I'm saying
find all sub-expressions right that's
correct and somebody has SW SH has put
on the live stream a suggestion for how
to do this place hat alright well let's
see where this works okay so this is
just saying I see so this is yeah this
is a good idea this is just saying find
with position oh my gosh okay there we
go
okay so okay let's just write this then
okay so let's call this Combinator cases
of an expression is what we get by
saying position let's find our
definition of Combinator of C pattern C
rules which we're going to need and down
here wherever it was um okay so position
in a exper and I don't know who need
heads to true do we does anybody know I
think what she so has it ready for okay
all right so that's gonna give us
okay so Combinator cases will tell us
where we could apply where we could in
principle apply one of those rules right
so Combinator cases of this says there's
only one case let's pick up a more
realistic example of this preferably not
something that a grotesque let's just do
this um so let's just do that like four
time three times okay so now we've got
an expression there and now we'll say
Combinator cases of that expression and
oh come on is that right
how can that be right oh no no no no no
no that we forgot an important thing
comma infinity here
am i totally confused position we want
to know the position level spec weld we
need a head skirts to all I think both
things are different they are yeah they
are actually okay so so what is going
wrong here so why is this not finding
because we know that we can apply
Searles to this yes at the at the out
the most well the outermost level we've
got that but this claim is the claim as
there is no more inner application right
folks correct all right okay well let's
try a different one of these okay maybe
we just were unlucky with our sample um
what's going on that compost may be
right because look see rules take this
expression and apply see rules to it oh
I have a much more horrifying idea did
it not do anything I don't understand
did it really not do anything to that
how can this then work it did something
but didn't do very much well okay yeah I
can see it did something that well the
fact that didn't do very much as its
prerogative but it certainly did
something more than nothing which is
what this is reporting here let me see
well there's something am I am I
confused is this a problem could this be
a problem okay I am fair
very confused um why didn't this work so
down here why is this not reporting any
position that matches either of these
well so first of all is there a position
that matches one of those so s oh okay
so that clearly matches right that there
clearly Matt no it doesn't match the S
pattern okay how does slash dot manage
to do something here when this doesn't
um yeah it's trying 0 infinity that's a
good suggestion what's going on okay
let's see what slash dot actually did oh
boy we need some kind of def of these
two expressions what this did is it
moved the K somehow inside there right
yes so there must be an S probably
applied it to the whole expression yeah
so I think you test no that s oh that I
see that that s is that that's the first
argument of the ass the second and case
there's the second argument of the third
argument of the ass sorry so it's it's
at the Altemus level and I think the
problem is that with this position thing
what why is the position not finding
that I don't know but well if you do
position you know X comma X it doesn't
it returns the same thing so I think it
just doesn't find if it's the whole
expression it returns an empty list oh
why is the zero level
oh because it's the part specification
it is this is a list of one element we
are just totally confused it's a list of
one element that is the part
specification of what you have see what
I'm saying right okay so I claim that
this is going to be more civilized if we
do this if we look at this with nest
list let's say eight here and then on
that we say Combinator cases okay much
more civilized okay so those are the
possible applications um of this um we
have suggestion here about how to
visualize these functions which would
certainly be useful okay
so here we've got um here we've got that
right so this is showing us where in the
expression
so in particular we could do the
following thing okay potential idea here
this this may be very very obscure so
let's say we say a map at of an
expression okay so Combinator framed of
a Combinator expression I'm suggesting
that they say map at of the Combinator
expression with I'm sorry map at framed
onto the Combinator expression with
Combinator cases of the expression okay
so what that should do if we if it's
right is if we could say here I could
say for example Combinator framed
okay so that's showing where the
applications of combinators happen in
those expressions
make sense or where they can happen so
now our I mean I would think that
notation with an application operate
there would be I think that frame this
is a big improvement okay well so let's
look into a slightly bigger case and say
15 or something here and I'm probably
gonna have to show smaller font um okay
so that is starting to show us the tree
of where things can be applied so
there's effectively going to show us
this is a piece of essentially the multi
way graph of where things can get
applied so our problem from an
evaluation order thing is to select all
the possible places where you could hit
next so to speak here which ones should
you actually do in a particular
foliation is this making sense so what
we did here was we picked a particular
sequence of of reductions for that
expression and then in each one of these
were saying where could we go next
in fact we go to a definite place next
but this is saying where could we go
next right and so the problem of you
know essentially fully ating this
evaluation front is to say where do we
choose to go next
just making sense to people and what
we're looking for is a parameterization
of where to go next
so I mean let's let's try to draw the
multi way graph from this so I think we
now have so Jonathan we're trying to
write down the state evolution function
for this right right right so it's a map
out of replace of the of Combinator
cases
I think so and then you actually other
than that's in the state equivalents
function if you only want to draw the
multi-way evolution graph that's all you
need everything else can just be no okay
fine so map at every place part no that
isn't quite right
no it's replace I think it's an app out
of replace oh I see um okay map out
replace onto hash of Combinator cases of
hash do you agree
seems plausible which we try to in some
particular case that's try applying that
to this expression here because we can
see what that did at the beginning I'm
not promising okay so the replace oh no
no we have to say see rules here and
that's not right either because we don't
want that we want a list don't we of the
results right right you need to nap over
Combinator cases I think so right so
what we want is a um I thought that we
can do that with a single thing I think
we need to or you probably could do with
the Korean in some way um
function of that at this is there it
great
oh okay what won't [ __ ] here
okay Combinator cases of E is Combinator
cases of that thing agreed
oh that's crazy
there we go much better okay so this
then is function of e there so that
should be that okay we've got our state
evolution function now what do we need
now you need a state equivalence
function and then everything else can be
not with the exception of the system a
equivalence function is just same q is
that correct
I think so okay yeah you do like you do
have to set the element other elements
of the Association that they can just be
null what are they if you bring up the
documentation from our QA system we can
we can see state event function so we
have to put all of these then
unfortunately so yeah
is there a good place in documentation
where I can pull those all out yeah in
scope there is an example I believe
right now if we
sistent types if it's where I think it
is let me just check that it is actually
there oh here we go here's one yeah it's
that
actually here why don't we just you just
yeah just replace it with that and
everything else is the same
okay so now here instead of that we will
have drumroll
this thing here this works I'll be
amazed so far I'm amazed um alright so
now let's make a state's graph of this
which will look awful by the way because
we don't have a recurring function maybe
do States power structure hmm odd
exceptionally odd that's saying there's
no branching here which seems extremely
implausible
well Combinator cases only returned one
element I understand that but but we
just had an example up here this is a
nest list on this you see what I'm
saying I don't understand how it did
that if this is correct right so here
right this is returning so this shows
that there are non-trivial that this is
claiming that there's only one way to do
this reduction right which seems
extremely implausible to me because we
already know there are multiple places
we can do the update right but this is
saying whatever the I mean that in that
case same queue returns true on all of
those updates if we believe the
evolution function then yes I don't
think it's correct because Lester that
what so let's see a vertex list or just
look at the old states list okay let's
take this thing here and then
say vertex list of that okay and let's
compare those with what we get by
actually doing the explicit um okay we
want the explicit evolution um which is
this one here right they're the same
well they seem to be the same okay so
this is saying that there's just a this
is completely incomprehensible to me but
this hat has a single path of evolution
can we not take one of we had examples
above where Combinator cases return
something that wasn't a singleton there
here it's full of things that aren't
Singleton's look at all these things
here each one of those boxes is a return
from Combinator cases see and then this
common thing each one each section here
right this this this whole thing here is
is full of different of multiple results
from Combinator cases hmm okay they're
just just my own sanity can we try maybe
the one that's you know there's they're
examples up there like one zero one one
one one and things can we try whatever
expression it was the correspondence of
those yeah it's the same thing it's the
same thing we're just doing the same
thing over and over again it's this one
here but we can do it I mean we can do
this here that was the first eight cases
of this right so okay let's look at this
okay so let's say the first five cases
of this alright let's now let's go but
for the first eight cases well how many
okay first eight cases now let's say
length slash at that okay so the first
few were all yes and maybe run the multi
way system for four more steps I did oh
I see oh I know what the problem is
it's exploit it I it's only doing one
update at a time yeah
but how did it manage to stop alright
let's live dangerously but I don't think
this Kompas I don't understand this
stopped as if it was a fixed point here
in other words Combinator cases what
this is basically saying is that
Combinator cases applied to that oh
that's a single result that says apply
it to everything right that's the and
it's the last the last one right the
last one above is the empty list here
yes
so should we modify the evolution
function to deal with that case yes but
how do we need to do that I mean so if
it's a null list what is it what is it
supposed to do it should just do replace
so your claim is that this map at here
in the case where the hash sign is why
doesn't map out to that correctly
let's just see what map app does in this
case okay so we're saying map at of F on
to let's say one two three with the
position for map app D it does the right
thing why didn't it do the right thing
then so what happens
you apply sea rules to that just to the
whole expression there is it is it a
fixed point okay so we say replace um I
can't even tell no that's different
there are two K's but yzma but finding
list of empty list or just the empty
list you're correct the problem is that
it item problem is that this map here is
doing the wrong thing so we have to say
then um well I mean the hack version of
this would be if somebody is pointing
out here map hat as suggesting map out
have replaced C rules oh I see you're
claiming that we could do this I don't
know if that's correct
we can try oh no no I do understand
nice thank you okay
oh very interesting all right so this
now okay so first thing this looks
awfully causal invariant to me look at
all those mergers we can even test
causal on variance for this comple yes
yeah why not you don't trust your cool
inversions checker well no it's a minute
it's it's SNK Combinator's because we
know look at that creature there's a
Combinator explosion if I ever saw one
alright so what we are trying to do is
to figure out in that mess well now we
can work out or we can work out the
multi way causal graph from this no we
cut why not
because we didn't give it a vendor
selection functions we yo yeah we need a
lot more information okay all right but
which actually is not too hard to right
now I mean if we're agreed that this is
the design I can easily put that
together well I don't think it is the
final design I think there's just a you
know there's just an exploratory design
okay um let's try one of these things
that eventually turns into a fixed point
this essex but the thing with pure s is
it turns into a fixed point um let's see
the largest fixed point case D and the
heck is case D growl
I need to know um so these are cases
that grow exponentially so let's try
this one you know clicking on a common
interest that has let's just try five
cases here
so it's interesting that takes a while
for these thing to start what this is
really weird I've never seen a thing
that does this where it takes so long to
kind of get started
oh no well we know it grows like wow
it's really weird not what we've seen in
other places where it sort of help help
no don't crash come on
how big is this we have no idea
formatting notebook contents let's see
what it's gonna happen this great I'm
just gonna try no this thing is
absolutely huge whatever it is is
absolutely monumentally huge by the way
do you know what color scheme it's using
for this multi way system is it using
its some kind of default for the yeah
yeah it's using the standard state node
coloring scheme the one that Jeremy
design okay I mean it's it wasn't
optimized for you know this number of
states so it looks a bit weird with the
gray arrows um this notebook is like
this must be like absolutely
monumentally huge okay let's see we got
215 there and it started to do things
I'm just gonna go to 17 because that's
about as far as I think I can go so
actually maybe we can get to 18 alright
so reminder of what's going on here so
this is showing this is the thing that
we need to foliate to be able to
understand the evaluation order for
combinators right um we're not foliated
we are defining a path which we can now
do incidentally I mean the week well
okay if you say okay apart to do the
recursive valuation but what I was
trying to do was to
give essentially something which says
which is a sort of a general definition
of what order to do these things in
you're right that it's not we're not
trying to get equivalence classes right
would you could do in the multi way
causal graph but that's a more
complicated case and requires notions of
spelling preparation one thing that okay
so the reason okay if we were trying to
evaluate the Combinator expression in
parallel then we would care about that
right because what this is saying is
there are pieces of this that are not
causal dependent right there are pieces
that could be done in parallel right so
there's a question of what can we
parallelize here so the foliation
question foliation is equivalent to sort
of um what camp do you agree people
agree here what can we parallel eyes so
what is the dependency graph here but um
okay we're even picking a path okay so
let's take this thing here align it by
eighteen let's say um layered graph plot
well let's just see what happens if we
say um I don't know what it's gonna do
graph 3d of one-eighth well that's kind
of very interesting it's rather rather
botanical I can just imagine picking one
of those blueberries um but not very
useful but the point is once we have a
event function specified then the that
Association allows you to specify an
event selection function which is what
we're talking about
indeed which will give us a path but
what criteria could be used for the
event selection function um
okay so this is quite interesting so
that's the layering
that's essentially layering by
evaluation by recursion level I think
think that's right
that shows us in the sort of
cosmological rest frame in effect the
the sequence of things where the number
of events that took place this is saying
at each level here there's a different
number of events that took place
different number of rewrite rule rewrite
events that took place I don't know
quite so so the question that we're
asking ourselves is if we want a path
through this let's find one that goes to
a fixed point but takes a while okay
because I think that's that's what's
going to be the most let's take a look
which one do we have here that went to a
fixed point what was the one that we had
up here this one here do we think we do
we want to live that dangerously we
might be able to do that one let's try
this one here okay so that's this thing
here and so that one what we should see
this may be hopeless we may have to take
a simpler case um fixed points are going
to be hard to spot in the multi way
evolution graph because their statements
about a single path no they're not it
goes to a normal form the multi
evolution going to and yeah going to a
normal form is a statement about a
single path no but but in this picture
because of the state equivalence
function every single thing it's just
going to go back to a single dot here
but you can have the thing can be
confluent are not uniformly confident
this is what this is the point I was
trying to make earlier
I mean well let's let's see how you can
have a compliment system where evolution
branches can be if it can be infinite
but you can still have some
branches where there's a normal form
okay well that's this question okay
great okay that's it that's we're gonna
see as usual the experiments clarify
what's going on so that could be it
could be been that both you and Matthew
are correct that every finite branch
terminates in the same thing but there
exist infinite branches that don't
terminate at all yes I I actually agree
that I had actually said that before
well yeah we are not in disagreement
about that point let's let's let's look
at this thing okay let's look at this
and let's see what it actually does okay
so let's say um let's define this as um
Combinator multi-way graph of x per and
T I think those are the only parameters
right okay so I'd say Combinator great
okay now it's starting to blow up I
think we're gonna have to try and find
one of these experimentally without that
isn't this is that the same expression
no it's completely different expression
so that was s is this is so this has
that same kind of structure which is
kind of interesting okay so let's try 14
Oh No okay that's already getting really
complicated so I think we're gonna have
to do this okay who knows how to get how
to generate all possible S Combinator
expressions can we go with groupings I
think we can do it with groupings and
construct coming not anybody else very
good for groupings okay so what but but
this isn't a unary thing is that it's it
isn't it a tree
now what the heck is it this is the
total number of Combinator expressions
is blah so I love the way that I just
say that um I wonder how I got that or
in general two to the N binomial of this
see page 897 let's try that the
Combinator expressions are just binary
trees where you replace the leaves with
either S or T okay okay so can we come
so how do we get binary trees we can get
binary trees some groupings Kambli yeah
it's grouping of it will be list it sank
a constructor goes to do and well we
need to put SS and case many times in
the first list okay fine fine let's just
do s expressions to begin with okay so
let's make a table of let's say five SS
okay so those are all the s expressions
that we can get with five SS right so
for each of those I'm going to live very
dangerously and I'm going to compute the
Combinator because since actually I know
that they all terminate because I
remember that um so this so let's say
ten steps and let's map that over this
collection of the S Combinator
expressions thrilling okay alright so
let's try going um I start going to the
next one up
mega thrilling well actually do we know
that we've gone enough steps see if we
go 10 whoops there we go 20 steps here
still the same thing okay let's try one
more time and that's some hard say graph
that image size tiny seven of these okay
let's see what happens now it's taking
forever but we're trying to find the
first example where but we could
actually we could actually just compute
I wonder whether any of these get huge
um
let's compute which of these doesn't
lead to a trivial fixed point argh
all right let's do this let's just say
nest list of hash slash slash dot C
rules no slash dot C rules on hash of
let's say I don't know ten steps and
then let's for that let's just say
length no leaf count slash that I should
really be using better functional
constructs here and now I use this
groupings thing and this should give me
the okay there we go so that's showing
what happens to each of those so they
mostly go to fixed points here okay
there's one that's doing something more
non-trivial so should we pick up let's
pick up one of these that well let's see
if they actually go to a fixed point so
let's say fifteen steps
okay so there's some that seem to be
growing without bound here so far as we
can tell
okay let's take this one here that light
goes to a fixed point that takes a few
steps to do it makes sense and that's
some for the sake of knowing what the
heck is going on let's do a hash goes to
that okay so this one here is one that
goes to a fixed point but takes a little
while makes sense so let's try that okay
all right this is going to be more
interesting so let's say v naught say
'let's we live okay yeah it's an
interesting object quite an amusing
object looks like the N one moon rocket
well look at that though look at that
that didn't change so what that's saying
is let's do a layered what version of
this okay that's wait there are cycles
well isn't that interesting closed
timelike curves so it's definitely not
causal invariant well in some weird
sense okay so hold on let's just let's
just get the layered version of this
okay now notice in the layered version
notice that everybody is going there I
don't see any cycles yeah okay there may
have just been an illusion so there
appears to be a fixed point let's let's
keep going for longer yeah it's a fixed
point okay so this is saying so this is
an example of a Combinator expression
okay so this is a great example of where
we can ask about the evaluation so any
particular evaluation order is a path
through this graph right and the
parallelization here is those nodes of
this graph that can be independently
computed correct
but only combined later all right
agree disagree well I disagree well
explain why well because the
parallelization is a question of multi
way causal connection not multi
revolution connection that's true you're
right you're right so what we need to do
then is to show on this also the causal
graph right so how would we can
the causal we need to then okay but this
is a nice example because this is a nice
example so so far there's no evidence
from this okay
it's just compute a few of these other
ones okay pick up pick another one that
you'd like here um I mean these all okay
let's check let's try this one here
which might not terminate okay
it doesn't look promising
well I agree but
you
cases oh there's this one here as well
all right let's try this one
and let's not be that dangerous great
that looks very non terminated but let's
take a look hmm
Wow these things grow quickly now can
you identify identical some expressions
we did that this is a state's graph this
is I believe this is this has already
marked part of that on the left is just
another copy of the whole thing right I
don't think so I think it's a copy of
the whole thing with potentially with an
S wrapped around it or something like
this it can be the case that every every
node here is a different expression or
any pair of nodes where same queue
returns true will be merged but same
queue these things are same queued
things there's no way to have
expressions that are different I'm
saying I mean I mean we could do that
you could you could set include step
number include state ID if you wanted to
not have that equivalence why would we
want that I don't know just to
illustrate the difference but I agree
it's not useful but I'd see if we can
get at the causal graph I mean okay so
what are we learning from this we're
learning here we've got a nice
presumably causal invariant thing that
goes to normal form right in this case
we've got something that you're claiming
isn't causal invariant well it doesn't
go to a normal form that's fairly it's
fairly likely at least from this picture
okay but but the the the squiggling out
of causal umbaran's by virtue of the
fact that so one question is is there a
path that gives a fixed point here and
another path that doesn't actually
actually hang all over if you go to the
far left there that's that's a normal
form why do you say that because they
way more reduction steps on the right
than there are for the ones on the left
unless I'm again P I'm not sure that's
correct
I'm not sure that's correct let's look
here on three four five maybe not I
don't know well okay so the question is
these are layers right but the problem
is because the evaluation order it's not
obvious to me that it did the right that
it you know that it that is tried
applying as many things on this side so
what we what we will want to do here
comparing these two things right yeah
hang wait no yeah it definitely has
reached a normal fault because look you
can see the same cluster of states above
and below on the left
well can I interrupt
yeah okay so can I back up for a second
and and reaffirm that that our goal is
to find an example where you have one
that has a fixed point when you evaluate
it some ways then goes off I mean
connealy evaluating if you evaluate if
you evaluate it in some other way
correct then which is the switch of this
example yeah okay no there so if we're
building our Combinator's only out of
s's um this is a special case of what's
known as the lambda I calculus and it's
known in that case that if it terminates
there is a specific number of
evaluations that will always terminate
every branch will terminate with within
that specific number of evaluations um
and that's the lambda I calculus and if
you just use s that's within the lambda
I calculus so you actually have to use K
if you want to get when a good case math
you answer the question which of these
endpoints here so we can tell which of
these is a fixed point right by just but
we could we could label these we could
let's let's do the following let's say
highlight let's take this graph okay and
then up argh okay so let's take that
graph there okay how many fixed points
can there be only one only one by the
currents are not real points
unless you claim Russell right okay so
if we take vertex list of this right
that's gonna give us all the things
which are okay so now now we can say fix
point Q right and the fixed point Q
would be is it the case that X bar so my
my fixed point test you tell me others
is right is um X / / / dot no that's a
very dangerous thing to do slash dot C
rules is that correct that's my test for
whether it reached a fixed point so what
I was gonna do here is I was gonna say
select invert XQ fixed point Q nothing
nada
none of them are fixed points so so as I
was saying we need to include K and I
can actually construct the accommodator
expression you're looking for if you
want me to construct it for you sure Jo
suppose this okay
first just as an abbreviation call the
expression s of K of K call that I say I
equals S sub K of K like that correct
just like that okay great um then let's
see call um D sits ad equals F of I of I
okay now take the expression K all and
an inside K give it D of D like that
correct just like that clean is this is
the expression you're looking for like
the droids sorry right um okay so your
claim is that this will achieve a fixed
point for some um it's a lovely looking
thing okay
no no III actually movement I actually
misspoke oh we have to make a slight
change let me think for a moment by the
way if we want to detect fixed points I
think there's a reasonably easy way to
do that what's wrong with this way of
doing it with it but we can figure out
which branches yield fixed points okay
because you can just get you can compute
the vertices that have out degree 0 and
then find shortest paths from the origin
to that vertex and then any that have a
path length that's less than the number
of steps are fixed points okay the
expression we want is actually K of K of
D D okay of D like that no no no no K is
for to create arguments the first
curried argument is K the second in a
deity huh all right so we're saying this
thing here um so you're making a claim
that this is gonna have one place where
it gets to a fixed point and the other
place where it's going to be um going
off like crazy
yeah the important point being D of D
what will keep computing forever but if
you evaluate the outer
it evaluates decay okay so explain what
you're seeing in this picture what are
you seeing here so that appears to be
everything seems to evoke all owing to
this there's nothing well we don't know
about that right so let's try it let's
go back for example four seven steps or
something and just see what it looks
like well the the d of d should keep
evaluating forever well shall I color
this in some way with the vertices which
I make the colors of the vertices
indicate what's going on you're saying
that there there should be a things with
head K do something different is that
right oh well there's that evaluating
that outer K is what brings you to your
normal form and if you don't evaluate
that then you can keep evaluating the
arguments of that K forever look there
are things here that appear to have
stopped right and there's another thing
down here that appears to be these
things here let me do my little trick
here with the with the normal forms I
mean that the fixed point Q thing okay
so let's take this and then let's say
and the vertex list there select in that
vertex list of that this fixed point Q
okay so that says
one thing here that is a fixed point
just K is a fixed point here and nothing
else says that's by the church water
properly it has to be ordered one well
so okay so let's find that one okay so
let's say K so in this picture here we
want to say um highlight graph of this
thing here comma and then we just want
to say K okay so the K is right down at
the bottom there I think one problem
might be that this infinity valuation is
over several steps and not over one step
because D was just an abbreviation so it
takes several steps until it to which
any weights I I really think it'll be
instructive if we look at the length of
the shortest paths
okay length of shortest path from what
to what so as I say we compute all of
the vertices without degree zero so
those are all of the all the ones which
are either normal forms or which are or
which have just been computed on the
last step alright so say select this
vertex out degree out degree 0 whoops
vertex list wait no hang on no no this
is completely wrong we need to get the
graph here we need to compute the graph
then we need to say vertex our degree in
that graph select a vertex list of GGG
the out degree there GGG is zero okay so
those are the vertices without degree
zero right so then if we do a find
shortest path from the original state to
all those we can see whether they are
equal to seven or whether they're less
than seven and we can color them
accordingly okay so find shortest path
this between the original expression
which is this thing here and let's just
look at length of that to begin with so
there's there's the fixed point which
the two yep I understand this is oh look
at this picture I see yeah we don't know
how its laid out that's why I'm saying I
think you should color it by the
shortest path lengths from the initial
state but the initial state should be at
the top why isn't the initial state at
the top why would it be at the top
because it's a layered graph plot
without the specified root vertex but
long let's specify its root vertex
places the
vertex our position okay so let's say
that that okay so let's do this let's
say they're um the root vertex let's
take this thing here okay explain what
the heck is going on why are there
multiple root vertices and why is the
thing going backwards there see those
arrows going up I am deeply confused is
that what we want to do the eye I don't
actually know how lair graph plot works
well it says here places the dominant
vertex in the plot at position pause do
we have an example of where that works
I mean it's nothing if nothing else we
can just highlight the draw Russian
alright let's just highlight it so in
this case instead of highlighting K
there we want to highlight the root okay
what that's what the heck is going on
there yeah but it's at the top but look
what it's doing the arrows are going up
to it some arrows are going up to it
there's a cycle other cyclists SII SII
creates a cycle right
once you have identity then yes I do you
applied to itself it evaluate after a
whole bunch of chains of evaluations
it reads D applied to itself and it does
that indefinitely do you applied to
itself though it should be applied to
itself evaluate to D applied to itself
so that might be what you're it so
there's a cycle I mean that's an example
of a cycle right so for example we could
take that um and we could say highlight
graph of that comma and then the cycle
great right and once you have a cycle
then you don't have you don't have
uniform confluence and therefore you
don't have cause learn variance well
that would otherwise be known as a
closed timelike curve yes mm-hmm
right okay
hmm okay so what do we learn from this
so what we're learning is that it is in
fact true that when the commentator
doesn't terminate then you can you may
not have cause lemare ends not
necessarily um I think you're seeing
loop because what you're doing is you're
identifying nodes with a specific
Combinator expression here we have the
same Combinator expression appearing
over and over again if you instead treat
them as different nodes the separate
separate times that it occurs at then
you won't get looped but you still won't
have uniform confluence well we can we
can do the thing you just said right if
we take state ID and then but the fact
that you still have you have non
uniformity in the in the path lengths so
you can't have uniform confluence and
that's what you can't have causal
variance I don't know what the notion of
uniform confluence is about here but
that you get caught that confluence only
makes a statement you know confluence is
the statement that every time you get a
bifurcation there exists a rewrite a
sequence that unifies it a uniform
confluence is the statement that that
sequence can be applied across all multi
way branches fair enough ok ok let's
take this and let's take the thing here
let's sum I don't know let's call it um
what should we call it aidid ok and now
this wants to say here we want to say
include what is it including state ID
arrow true makes it ok so then let's
take this thing here and we're living a
bit dangerously by saying 7 here but
let's try it anyway um Aidid hmm ok not
so bad
ok then let's do the lad Croft part of
that
well let's do this whole thing here why
not actually hang a weight you might
want to do include state ID and includes
step number just to be on the safe side
what well I don't we don't need the
highlight golf here so we don't care
about that ID'd a little ice I see I see
because we don't have the IDs in there
you have it
yeah we don't have that vertex okay that
didn't make any difference did it thing
like that is the same as yeah I'm a
little bit concerned because that does
still seem to be a cycle down I'm trying
to work out why a cycle even when you
include the IDS it looks like it but I
can't tell if where do you think those
are so a non layered graph lot
yeah it's compute this up whether
there's a cycle yes what's this so what
what's that that's the state ID right
yes why this hang on hang on hang on
oh yeah okay yeah no I understand we
need to we need to specify the events
functions because they're the way that
the state IDs are assembled is that
there's problems is from the event IDs
the input and output event IDs which we
haven't specified um right so does in
fact incorrect yep but if we can we get
the event thing in there I mean cuz that
would be a then we could get the causal
so when you say the event think there
are several event functions
the event decomposition function will be
non-trivial - right do we need it to get
an event yes we do need to get the
causal graph right right what does it
need to do so it needs to figure out
which sub expressions were created and
destroyed by a particular event which
will depend on C rules why isn't it just
the position I mean that which cell
expression was created and destroyed
isn't that just the every time it does
an application right but with the map
app thing it knows from Combinator cases
it knows which ones are going to get
destroyed Combinator cases is the ones
that get destroyed and the result of
this is the ones that get created
correct yes but the the effectively you
have to do a diff in order to work out
which because which are going to be
created depends on what's no it doesn't
just depend on the right hand side it
also differs have to sort of mod out by
the left hand side okay but even in the
strings case it's not straightforward -
right I mean it's it won't be too
difficult but I don't think we can
reasonably do it in this meeting fair
enough okay but but so let's let's zoom
out a little bit what we think we've
learnt here okay what we haven't learnt
because we don't have the causal
dependence stuff is this paralyzation
what we we also well we're still mildly
confused what what do we think the
conclusion is about uh about the causal
and variance question in other words is
it the case that is it the case you can
get stuck in the multi-way graph and not
be able to get back you'll always be a
to get back but my point is okay it may
be freezing it this way will be more
helpful uniform calls uniform confluence
is a necessary condition for causal
invariants for the following reason if
you don't have uniform confluence so in
other words you have multi way branches
which for instance you know extend
infinitely even though there is
effective confluence on other branches
you can always make the causal graph
arbitrarily different by just following
that multi way branch or another step
alright don't I I don't necessarily buy
that that works infinitely but yeah I
understand the claim it's not what why
wouldn't it work infinite it's even
worse in the infinite case right do you
have a bunch of branches that all that
all terminate at some normal form but
you have one branch that's going up to
infinity then even if the calls and
graphs with all terminators are no the
causal graphs corresponding to the
branches that all terminate at a normal
form or isomorphic then the one that's
infinite definitely won't be because you
know you know I see the time I
understanding the causal so I don't
think unless I know maybe Matthew has a
different I don't think you can have
causal invariance if you don't have
uniform confluence and I'm pretty sure I
have a proof but I feel I I don't have
an opinion right away okay Matthew has
not halted he's not it's some uh ok ok
well ok let's go back again zoom out to
again what the original question was the
original question has to do with
parameterizing evaluation orders okay
which might seem I mean I think you guys
still haven't understood I think this is
a really I I think if we can really
figure this out this is really useful
although you know we're we're in the
depths of the abstraction of combinators
here but but I I don't think this is a
problem specific to combinators I think
no of course it's not a problems with
Surya this is the general theorem
proving problem of how do you how do you
specify you know the evaluation front
you know how do you specify what the
inputs to the lemons are sure I mean
look in theorem proving the the goal is
to find a path through a graph like this
through a mouth
we're graph that gets you from you know
left hand side to right hand side that's
the typical equation or theorem proving
problem and so to say you know well I'm
going to favor these pods over those
powers sure that's that's a worthwhile
thing to do right and that's I mean
that's a it's the same problem as the
problem of um you know for the Fibonacci
evaluation of the recursive function
which thing do you do first there it's
the same problem as depth-first
breadth-first parameterizing those it's
all the same problem I mean in other
words what we've got well okay to what
extent is it the same as finding a total
order consistent with a given partial
order
I think it's highly related to that
right because
I mean we're not seeing that exactly
here because we don't have a causal
graph but but I mean that at least is a
closely related problem and the problem
with that problem is that right now the
formalism we have what are some
reasonable total orders of a given
partial order
and that's what we were looking at in
those previous pictures and the answer
is there a large number of possible
partial orders and they're mostly our
was it um
oh I have to show you that Shawn Finkel
note here we go
the um okay so in general right these
are possible these are possible total
orders of this partial ordering right
that's a total order of that partial
ordering it's a total mess we don't care
about that one question is how do we
parameterize which total orderings we
care about you know depth-first
breadth-first
maybe that's what I think is going to
you know I think there are primitives to
represent these different orderings and
that these will be related to this
question about which path do you pick I
mean I'm looking for how do we think
about this because to me okay
there's a basic question as a physics
question okay this is a Jose type Jose
it I who have been very silent physics
type question okay we're parameterizing
reference frames we know what an
inertial frame is you know it's just a
frame that is you know progressive
slices what are some other examples of
types of frames that we are familiar
with
you accelerated frames props
yeah and rotating frames okay
so what are the interpretations of those
in this context because an inertial
frame is something where we are
effectively and maybe Jonathan already
knows the answer I don't know to this I
mean an inertial frame is something
where we basically have you know this is
the cosmological rest frame that we're
you know we plotted this in sort of the
cosmological rest frame so in that frame
the you know motionless inertial frame
is just horizontal slices going down and
the you know inertial frame at a given
velocity is horizontal slices tipped at
some angle
what is the accelerating frame well
horizontal slices tipped at this as a
success of the increasing angle where
you say successively increasing you mean
over time the angle gets to be larger
and larger is that right
certainly be one way of representing
that I think so in other words what
you're saying is that that means that
there is a I mean there is a singularity
in the accelerating frame if you try to
extend it to infinity right right and so
that's saying that those those frames
will eventually crash into each other
is that correct so in other words if you
take successive lines successive you
know when I hate to be you know ah
you're saying that what we would have
there is instead of saying we'll make a
table of lines that go instead of I mean
so the the ordinary case of a of a frame
with a given um would be let's say 0
would say we want the y direction 0 Y
and then X
seit NY or something would be table of
that Y goes from zero to minus 10 or
something and then that this would be
our trivial motionless what what are you
wrong
oops graphics not growth um now what is
wrong here
mine's Eero why
earth to those are wrong you did zero to
minus 10 so it's an empty value of wise
oh oh good point okay there's our frames
okay
okay so now a frame of a given velocity
would be presumably this thing with ten
going from that Y value there to this
thing you know 1.2 times y is that right
no all right because what I want to do
I'm sorry y plus
plus a constant plus 1.2 that thing I
just did was more like the accelerating
frame cases that correct yeah I think so
all right so this so is that right in
fact that that would be it let's say 1.5
ways that in fact hmm
well right that's not as uniformly
accelerating frame rate a uniform
accelerating frame is being to generate
like a privilege right yes those frames
don't crash into each other so they have
to go somewhere well so you're saying in
that case the what we would have is a
bunch of curves here where each curve
has a derivative hyperbolas are
parabolas what what does it make I mean
it's a if it's uniform acceleration
normally naively it would be a parabola
right no right because can't right there
because then it would eventually be
going faster than light right but saying
an accelerated frame that if we take
account of that that we have to put in
I'm not yes I understand what you're
saying you're saying that we have to
have something which has a square root
of 1 minus beta squared in it basically
yes okay
we should play wrap up here we're way
over time but have people at least
understood what the putt why I think
this is interesting no
does anybody other than me find this
hinge as did I find it very interesting
to represent these various strategies or
evaluation paths which I've never seen
before like this yeah I mean this is I
didn't want to do this for 40 years
I just haven't you know I've never found
a way to think about this I think that
there are primitives for picking
evaluation paths we just don't know what
they are
I had a version of the mass MP that
nobody understood the goal is to find a
way to pick these evaluation paths that
are it is understandable um I'm gonna
I'm gonna finish with the the this thing
this is these notes from curry from 1927
about Shan Finkle and Combinator's and
this is the that's K that's s as the S
Combinator and there's the unfortunate
thing let's see correspond to the
Scheffer formal stroke function the heck
is why is he talking about shove a
stroke here because iron does the the
right when Rd called shuffle algebras
right so they're sort of done exactly
what the correspondence is but okay
that's sad part of this this story is it
says here on discovery this paper I sort
of us of Veblen shown finkles paper said
it in that's probably German right and
Moscow Oh MOT in Moscow um accordingly
we sought out Paul Alexandrov okay I see
in Moscow on shown wrinkles paper right
the letter says Sean Finkel has since
gone insane and is now in a sanatorium
which is not a good you know not a good
outcome for you know as the fixed point
of working on combinators um you know
that's sort of what happened to Cantor
as well you know I know I know I know
this is the all right right this is the
problem that when the abstraction level
that's too high it's hard to stay
grounded so to speak um and um anyway I
mean the all right well we should
probably wrap up here but but I'm still
I'm gonna come back to this because I
still think there's something really
interesting here you know I think that
the thing what we're going to come up
with in the end is some way to define
which amounts to something like
reference frames to define what you know
to parametrize strategies for evaluation
and I think it's going to be I mean I
think there's gonna be a calculus for
example let's say we're connecting
reference frames right we have a notion
in you know in the standard continuum
general relativity we have ways to think
about connection reference frames
although it's a bit of a mess with
coordinate patches
so is there some natural interpretation
of say leftmost outermost or innermost
I'm sure that there is in terms of this
I mean in you know in this graph right
in one of these graphs leftmost
outermost is a path here we just have to
understand how to specify that path as
one of as one example in our
parameterization so is there a way to I
mean to uniformly specify that you
always want the leftmost outermost part
well undoubtedly it's a symbolic level
yes but the question is can we can we
see what that means I mean I I don't
know I mean look none of the things we
have here clearly what we've got here is
kind of messy we're picking out where
the possible places to act are and then
we are you know just doing a replace
part at that place right so it's not a
particularly convenient way to do this
um yeah I mean look I know okay all
right well we should um this has made
good progress I mean we have we haven't
solved the problem that um I feel like
this is good progress um and um
hmm okay all right well we should wrap
up here um and um I don't think we've
you know we have not solved the problem
yet but so you'll be hearing will be
grinding on this some more but we are we
are you know making progress all right
thanks everybody and Jonathan you and I
have a different topic to talk about
here so if we can um okay all right
thanks a lot
I'm thanks to folks on the livestream I
hope this was a bit abstract today um
but hopefully of some interest Thanks
okay see y'all soon okay bye